welcome to my presentation on domain of
a function so what's the domain the
domain of a function you'll often hear
it combined with domain and range but
the domain of a function is just what
values can i put into a function and get
a valid output so let's start with some
example let's say let me make sure my
pen is all set up let's say i had
oh wrong color
pick a nice color color okay let's say i
had f of x
is equal to um
let's say x squared
x squared
so let me ask you a question what values
of x can i put in here so i get a valid
answer for x squared
well i can really put anything in here
right any any real number so here i'll
say that the domain
domain
is the set
of x's such that x is a member of the
real numbers
this is just a fancy uh way of saying
that okay this this r with this kind of
double backbone here that just means
real numbers and i think you're familiar
with real numbers now that's pretty much
every number uh outside of the complex
numbers and if you don't know what
complex numbers are that's fine you
probably won't need to know it right now
the real numbers are are every number
that most people are familiar with
including irrational numbers including
transcendental numbers including
fractions every number is a real number
so the domain here is x x just has to be
a member of the real numbers and this
little backwards looking e or something
this means just means x is a member of
the real numbers so let's do another one
a slight variation somehow my circle
tool got changed
let's see
okay so let's say i had
f of x
is equal to
1 over x squared
so this is the same thing now can i
still put any x value in here and get a
a reasonable answer
well what's f of zero
something happened to my pen
see
oh
what happened to my pen
see f
of 0
is equal to 1 over 0. and what's 1 over
i don't know what it is so so this is
this is undefined
undefined no one ever took the trouble
to define what one over zero should be
and they probably didn't do it some
people probably thought about what it
should be but um
they probably couldn't find out with a
good definition for one over zero that's
consistent with the rest of mathematics
so one over zero stays undefined so f of
0 is undefined so we can't put 0 in and
get a valid answer for f of 0. so here
we say the domain
domain
is equal to
the little brackets that shows kind of
the set of what x's apply that's those
little curly brackets didn't draw it
that well
x is a member of the real numbers
still
such that
x
does not equal
zero
so here i just made a slight variation
on what i had before
before we said for when f of x is equal
to x squared that x is just any real
number
now we're saying that x is any real
except for zero this is just a fancy way
of saying and then these curly brackets
just mean a set
let's do a couple of more ones
let's say
f of x
is equal
my pen is i have to find a better way
let's see is equal to
the square root
of x
minus 3.
so just you know up here we said well
this this function isn't defined when we
get a zero in the denominator well
what's interesting about this function
can we take a square root of a negative
number
well until we learn about imaginary and
complex numbers we can't so here we say
well any x is valid here except for the
x's that make
this expression under the radical sign
negative so we have to say that x
minus three has to be greater than or
equal to zero correct because you could
have the square root of zero that's fine
it's just zero so x has to be greater
than or equal x minus three has to be
greater than or equal to zero so x has
to be greater than or equal to
three so here our domain is
let me make sure i have enough space x
is a member
of the real numbers
such that
x
is greater than or equal to 3.
bam
let's do a
slightly
more difficult one what if i said
f of x
f of x is equal to
the square root
of the absolute value of x
minus 3.
so now it's getting a little bit more
complicated well just like this time
around this expression of the radical
still has to be greater than or equal to
zero so we can just say that the
absolute value of x
minus three
is greater than or equal to zero
so we have the absolute value of x has
to be greater than or equal to three
and if order for the absolute value of
something to be greater than or equal to
something that that means that
the neg that means that x
has to be
less than or equal to negative 3
or
x has to be greater than or equal to 3
right it makes sense because
x can't be negative 2 right because
negative 2 has an absolute value less
than 3. so x has to be less than
negative 3. it has to be
further in the negative direction than
negative 3 or it has to be further in
the positive direction than positive 3.
so once again
x has to be less than negative 3 or x
has to be greater than 3 so we have our
domain so we have it is x is a member of
the reals
what's that
i actually always forget it's such that
the line i forget it's either a colon or
a line i'm i'm i'm rusty it's been years
since i've done this kind of stuff but
anyway i think you get the point
it could be any real number here as long
as x is less than negative 3 less than
or equal to negative 3 or
x is
greater than or equal to 3.
well let me ask a question now
what if instead of this it was
oh my pen
my pen let's say instead of this
we that was the denominator so let me
this is all a separate problem up here
so now we have 1 over the square root of
the absolute value of x minus 3.
so now how does this change the
situation so now not only does this
expression in the denominator not only
does this have to be greater than or
equal to zero can it be zero anymore
well no because then you would get the
square root of zero which is zero and
you get a
zero in the denominator so it's kind of
like this problem plus this problem
combined
so now when you have one over
the square root of the absolute value of
x minus three now
it's no longer greater than or equal to
zero it's just greater than zero
right it's just greater than zero
because we can't have a zero here in the
denominator so if it's greater than zero
then then we get rid of uh let me just
say greater than three and essentially
you just get rid of the equal signs
right here let me let me erase it
properly
you get it's a slightly different color
but maybe you won't notice
so there you go so that's
actually let me just do another example
since we have time
um
let's see let me erase this
okay now let's say that
oh my pen is let's see
oh i'm using the wrong color that's why
let's say that f
i don't oh yeah i know
let's say that f of x
is equal to
if x
is even
and
1 over
x
minus 2
times x minus 1
if
x
is odd
what's the domain here
what is a valid x i can put in here so
immediately
we have two clauses if x is even we use
this clause so f of let's oh man my pen
messed up again so let's say
let's say that f
of 4 well that's that's just equal to 2
because we use this clause here but this
clause applies when x is odd and just
like we did in the last example what are
the situations where this
kind of breaks down
well when the denominator is 0. well the
denominator is 0 when x is equal to 2
or x is equal to 1
right
but this clause only applies when x is
odd so x is equal to 2 will apply to
this clause so only x is equal to 1
would apply to this clause so we can
only have so the domain is
x
it's a member of the reals
such that
x does not equal
one
i think that's all the time i have for
now
have fun practicing these domain
problems